Catedrática Tamar Gendler:
La clase de hoy es
sobre el reto que Glaucón
planteó en el relato del
anillo de Giges.
La pregunta es:
¿qué motivaciones tenemos
para actuar moralmente?,
¿qué expectativas deberíamos tener
sobre quienes nos rodean?,
¿actúan así por razones intrínsecas
a una motivación moral o
solo porque quieren
aparentar que es así?
Primero, quiero hablar un poco
de la persona extraordinaria
que escribió los diálogos
de La República
que leímos hoy.
Es difícil sobrestimar la
influencia de Platón
en la tradición intelectual occidental.
No hay una persona culta en occidente,
en los últimos 2500 años, que
no haya sido influenciada
de alguna manera por el pensamiento
y el marco de entendimiento
que Platón nos dio hace
unos 2500 años.
Platón era un personaje
muy interesante.
Nació en una familia
aristocrática en Atenas.
Algunos creen que era descendiente de
uno de los reyes de Atenas,
sea como sea, su familia
estaba entre los líderes de la
sociedad política de Atenas.
Varios de sus tíos participaron en
un golpe de estado contra el
gobierno, años antes de que Platón
llegara a la edad adulta.
Se esperaba que alguien como
Platón se dedicaría
a la administración pública o al
gobierno, que sería un líder público.
Es como si fuera un Kennedy,
un Bush o un Clinton.
Venía de una familia con
una gran trayectoria
de participación política.
Se suponía que él se
dedicaría a la política.
Curiosamente, por cuestiones sobre
las que se especula mucho,
Platón cayó bajo la influencia de un
hombre 30 años mayor que él,
llamado Sócrates, quien, en los
retratos que hay sobre él
se parece demasiado a Platón.
Sócrates era un provocador.
Se paseaba por Atenas
pidiendo a la gente
que reflexionara sobre sus obligaciones.
Les pedía que pensaran cuál era
la naturaleza fundamental
de conceptos como justicia,
verdad, realidad, amistad,
amor y honestidad.
Les pedía que reflexionaran
sobre las ideas populares,
que se preguntaran cuáles
de sus creencias
tenían buenos fundamentos y cuáles
eran simples creencias populares.
Debido en parte a sus provocaciones,
Sócrates fue sentenciado a
muerte en 399 a. e. c.
Cuando Platón tenía apenas 30 años,
presenció la muerte de su gran maestro.
Y describe la historia del juicio en
el que Sócrates fue acusado
de corromper a la juventud ateniense
en un diálogo extraordinario
llamado La Apología.
El legado de La Apología es
comparable con el legado
de los evangelios sobre la
vida de Jesús.
Es la historia de una persona
dispuesta a morir por sus principios,
en cierta manera se convirtió en un tropo
de la civilización occidental.
En una pintura extraordinaria, que
pueden ver en el Museo Metropolitano
de Nueva York, hay una
representación de la muerte de
Sócrates.
Aquí está Sócrates bebiendo
del cáliz de cicuta
que lo matará.
Están sus discípulos,
incluyendo Platón,
calmado al pie de la cama, y
Crito, sujetando su pierna.
Subiendo las escaleras,
aunque no lo vean,
hay otros personajes retirándose.
Lo extraordinario es que
esta pintura fue hecha
en 1787 por uno de los artistas
involucrados en la revolución francesa.
De hecho, fue mostrada a Thomas
Jefferson y la admiró profundamente.
Llama la atención que su composición,
de cierta manera, evoca la famosa
pintura de Leonardo da Vinci,
La última cena, quienes
la conocen saben
que Jesús está sentado en el centro de la
mesa rodeado de sus discípulos.
En una historia, Jesús muere por la fe
y en la otra, Sócrates
muere por la razón.
La idea de que una vida basada en
principios, preservada
por discípulos que puedan explicar
la motivación de esa vida,
sea capaz de influir cientos de
años de la historia
y pueda inspirar cambio político y
compromisos basados en principios,
es uno de los legados de Platón.
Tras la muerte de Sócrates,
Platón se dedicó a estudiar.
En 385 a.C.
comenzó lo que muchos llamaron la
primera universidad o academia
en el mundo occidental.
En esa academia, Platón
formó a muchos pensadores
de la antigua Atenas,
incluyendo a Aristóteles,
cuyas obras leeremos la
siguiente semana.
En esa época, Platón escribió
varias obras que han perdurado.
Entre ellas, está La República,
de la que leímos fragmentos hoy.
Aquí está un manuscrito
especialmente bello, del siglo III,
de La República, uno de las
decenas de miles de documentos
descubiertos en Oxirrinco, Egipto,
hace aproximadamente un siglo.
Lo escribí aquí
para quienes estén
interesados en investigar
la historia de los papiros de Oxirrinco.
Es una de las historias de
detectives más increíbles
en la que se descubre un gran
tesoro de documentos.
Repito, hace solo un siglo, muchos
documentos se recuperaron
apenas, durante y después de la
primera guerra mundial.
La República, es uno de los
aproximadamente 30 diálogos
que escribió Platón.
Habrán notado al leerlo,
según lo indicaba la guía de lectura,
que no está escrito como un tratado.
Está escrito como una conversación.
A excepción de algunas cartas
que tenemos de Platón,
casi todas sus obras que conocemos
están escritas como diálogos.
Y abordan casi cualquier tema
filosófico imaginable.
La naturaleza del
conocimiento, de la verdad,
del amor, de la amistad, etc.
La República, en particular, se
centra en la cuestión
de cómo se debería
estructurar la sociedad
para permitir que los seres
humanos prosperen.
La obra, según la hemos heredado,
está estructurada en 10 libros;
en esta clase leeremos
fragmentos del segundo
y casi todo el décimo.
En el fragmento que estamos leyendo,
escuchamos una conversación
entre 3 personajes.
Uno es el maestro de Platón, Sócrates,
el hombre de la nariz respingada
que les enseñé en la otra diapositiva,
y los otros dos, son los hermanos de
Platón, Glaucón y Adimanto.
La conversación comienza
entre Sócrates
y Glaucón, y continúa entre
Sócrates y Adimanto.
Obviamente, no la estamos leyendo
del papiro de Oxirrinco.
Ni siquiera estamos leyendo el
texto original en griego
como algunos estudiantes de
Yale este semestre.
Mi departamento ofrece un seminario
sobre La República de Platón,
un semestre entero, en el que se lee
la obra en griego antiguo.
Hay una increíble colaboración,
de una década, entre Yale y la
Universidad de Londres
durante la cual, una semana al
año, catedráticos de Yale
y de Londres se reúnen para leer
un libro de La República.
Es un libro que aquí se
lee muy en serio.
Nosotros tenemos la fortuna
de leer una edición,
que les pedí que
compraran, que se ve así.
Quiero explicarles por qué les
pedí comprar el libro,
siendo que, como muchos
ya habrán visto,
la traducción de La República
de Benjamin Jowett, de
fines del siglo XIX,
está disponible en Internet.
Quiero explicar la importancia
de tener ediciones que están diseñadas
para ayudar a que los alumnos se
interesen realmente en el contenido.
En la copia de La República que
les pedí que compraran,
hay una gran cantidad de
materiales preliminares.
Hay notas al pie sumamente útiles.
Hay una bibliografía comentada
en el material preliminar
que les dice qué libros consultar si
están interesados en Platón.
Hay un índice muy valioso.
En los márgenes,
están los números de Stephanus
que sirven como referencia
para otras traducciones.
Pasemos a la sustancia del material
que leímos para hoy.
¿Qué es lo que intenta hacer
Glaucón, el hermano de Platón,
en su conversación con Sócrates?
Hay 3 preguntas que Glaucón
quiere responder.
Primero, quiere decir algo
sobre la naturaleza
y el origen de la justicia.
¿Por qué la gente se comporta
de forma colaborativa?
¿A qué nos referimos cuando hablamos
de las normas de la justicia?
Esto lo discutiremos cuando
lleguemos a Hobbes,
así que hoy no diré más
del argumento que Glaucón
ofrece al respecto.
En cambio, quiero centrarme en 2 cosas:
la segunda y la tercera
pregunta de Glaucón.
En primer lugar, Glaucón afirma
que la gente actúa de forma
justa de mala gana,
que su única razón para
cumplir y aceptar
las leyes morales
es poder obtener una buena reputación.
En segundo lugar,
Glaucón afirma que la gente
tiene razón en actuar así.
Entonces, el texto comienza con
una comparación básica.
Una comparación útil,
no solo en el contexto de la discusión
de Glaucón sobre la justicia
sino que es fundamental en
toda la obra de Platón:
la comparación entre lo que parecen
y lo que son las cosas.
Es crucial reconocer
que parecer y ser son cosas
distintas, y que a veces
nos preocupa lo que parece
y a veces, lo que es.
El texto comienza
con un reto que Glaucón
plantea a Sócrates. Dice:
¿Quieres que parezca que
nos has convencido
de que es mejor ser justo que injusto?
¿O de verdad quieres convencernos?
Obviamente, Sócrates busca lo último.
Quiere persuadir de verdad.
Glaucón vuelve al tema de
parecer contra ser
y pregunta a Sócrates:
¿Es valioso ser justo?
¿O el valor de la justicia
viene del simple hecho de parecer justo?
Encontramos una comparación, en
las primeras páginas,
entre 3 tipos de valores que
tienen las cosas.
Las cosas pueden ser
valiosas intrínsecamente:
valiosas como fines en sí mismas,
valiosas por lo que son.
Sócrates pone como ejemplo el júbilo
y otros placeres inofensivos.
Son cosas que valoramos
no por las cosas adicionales
que proporcionan,
sino que las valoramos como
fines en sí mismos.
Por el contrario,
hay cosas que solo tienen un
valor instrumental.
Cosas que son valiosas como medios.
Cosas que son valiosas porque nos
permiten hacer algo más
o nos permiten aparentar algo.
En esta categoría caen cosas como
el dinero, que es valioso,
permítanme recordarles, no
como un fin en sí mismo,
sino como un medio para otros fines.
Y, por ejemplo, cosas como
parecer peligroso.
Intentamos desde el punto de
vista de la evolución,
o como país, evitar que
otros nos ataquen,
no importa si somos peligrosos o no.
Lo que importa es parecer peligrosos.
Y, por supuesto,
hay cosas que son valiosas
por ambas razones.
Cosas como la vista, dice Sócrates,
que la valoramos porque nos
permite hacer cosas
y porque nos produce un
placer por sí misma.
La salud. El aprendizaje.
El conocimiento.
Glaucón y Sócrates se preguntan
en qué categoría está la justicia.
Si tuviéramos nuestros clickers,
sería mi oportunidad para
volver a captar su atención
y preguntarles en qué
categoría considera Glaucón
que está la justicia y en qué
categoría la considera Sócrates.
Pero en nuestro último día
de baja tecnología,
les pediré que levanten la mano.
¿En qué categoría
cae la justicia según Glaucón?
¿Es valiosa intrínsecamente,
instrumentalmente o ambas?
¿Quiénes creen que él piensa
que la justicia solo tiene
valor intrínseco?
[pausa]
¿Quiénes creen que él piensa
que solo tiene valor instrumental?
[pausa]
¿Quiénes creen que él
piensa que tiene ambos?
[pausa]
Por el otro lado, Sócrates:
¿Valor intrínseco?
[pausa]
¿Valor instrumental?
¿Ambos?
[pausa]
Hay una polémica entre ellos.
Ambos suponen que hay valor
en parecer justo,
pero la polémica está en si,
además, es valioso ser justo.
¿Es importante actuar de forma justa
o solo importa aparentar que se
actúa de forma justa?
Para responder a esta pregunta,
Glaucón, como un personaje en La
República de Platón,
usa una técnica que se ha convertido
en una de las técnicas fundamentales
del pensamiento filosófico.
Esencialmente,
es una aplicación del método
científico a nuestra idea.
Si intentas descubrir qué hace
que una semilla crezca,
¿necesita tierra,
agua, luz, aire?,
¿necesita que le cantes
cuando pasas cerca?,
entonces, realizas un
experimento controlado
y observas.
Si tienes la semilla con agua,
pero sin tierra, ¿crece?
Si tienes la semilla con aire,
pero no le cantas, ¿crece?
Glaucón plantea una serie de
ejercicios imaginarios
para preguntarse qué haría la
gente si el comportamiento
no tuviera sus típicas consecuencias.
Nos pide que nos imaginemos
a alguien que actúa de
manera justa o injusta.
Y que pensemos cuáles
serían sus motivaciones
si las consecuencias fueran de
un tipo determinado.
En general, si actúas
moralmente, eres percibido
como que actúas moralmente; si
actúas inmoralmente,
eres percibido como que
actúas inmoralmente.
En la historia del anillo de Giges,
que les conté la clase pasada,
Glaucón nos pregunta cómo
actuaría la gente
si fuera percibida igual
sin importar su comportamiento real.
Si tu acto inmoral fuera
invisible para el mundo,
si pudieras actuar inmoralmente
y nadie te viera, si tu
reputación permaneciera intacta,
¿cómo te comportarías?
Glaucón sugiere con la
historia del anillo de Giges
que bajo esas circunstancias,
te comportarías igual que el injusto.
Pero si no te ha
convencido esa historia,
cuenta otra historia después de esa.
Es la historia de la
inversión y dice esto:
Supón que la persona que
actúa de forma justa
es percibida por todos como
injusta y que la persona
que actúa de forma injusta es
percibida como justa.
¿Seguirías actuando
según los estándares
de moralidad si obtuvieras la
reputación contraria?
Podemos comparar esta
cuestión sobre moralidad
con 2 casos donde parece estar claro
que en el primero, valoramos
algo solo de forma
instrumental y en el segundo,
valoramos algo de forma
intrínseca e instrumental.
El acto consiste en tomar
una medicina asquerosa, que en
circunstancias normales,
cuando la tomas mejoras
y cuando no la tomas sigues enfermo.
Entonces, se supone que si quieres
mejorar, tomas la medicina.
En un escenario tipo Giges, en el que
mejoras tomes o no la medicina,
no tendrás motivación para tomarla.
Sin duda, en un escenario contrario
en el que tomas la medicina
y sigues enfermo, y si no
la tomas, mejoras,
no tendrías motivación para tomarla.
Cuando las cosas solo tienen
un valor instrumental,
podemos ver la motivación
según las consecuencias.
La pregunta es: ¿la justicia es
como tomar una medicina?,
¿la valoramos por algún
fin que produce,
pero no por la medicina en sí?
¿o es algo como la vista?
Supongamos que, tal y como sucede
en circunstancias normales,
cuando ves, tienes una
experiencia visual del mundo
y cuando realizas una actividad motriz,
no chocas con cosas.
Debido a que puedo ver este podio,
puedo regular mi cuerpo
y evitar chocar con él. En un
escenario tipo Giges,
no necesitaría ver para evitar
chocar contra el podio.
Está claro que en ese caso,
preferiría ver aunque pudiera tener
las consecuencias de la vista
incluso si no viera.
¿Qué haría en el caso
inverso? Si pudiera
tener la vista o la habilidad para
no chocar con los objetos,
o la habilidad para no
chocar pero no lo vista;
no sé qué responder.
El reto que Glaucón
plantea es el siguiente:
¿La moralidad es para ti
una simple medicina?
¿Actúas con moralidad para
tener una reputación
de actuar moralmente?
¿O actúas moralmente porque la
moralidad, al igual que la vista,
es valiosa en sí misma para ti
y valiosa por las
consecuencias que produce?
Ese es el reto de La
República de Platón.
En las próximas 2 semanas veremos
algunas de las respuestas
que se ofrecen al reto de Glaucón.
Quiero pasar al segundo texto
que leímos para hoy.
Un texto del psicólogo
contemporáneo Daniel Batson,
que aborda la cuestión de la
integridad moral y la hipocresía moral
desde una perspectiva
psicológica empírica.
La pregunta de Batson es: ¿la gente
tiene el objetivo de ser moral
o simplemente de parecer moral?
Batson no se parece a
Platón ni a Sócrates.
Está vivo. Da clases en la
Universidad de Kansas.
Incluso tiene una impresora. En el
texto que leímos para hoy,
se describen los estudios
empíricos de Batson
sobre la cuestión de cómo se portan
las personas cuando piensan
que no son observadas.
¿Cómo interpretan sus
acciones ante sí mismas?
¿Qué factores, si los hay,
las llevan a actuar
de formas más honestas? Batson
presenta a los sujetos
un escenario experimental muy sencillo.
Las personas que participan en el
experimento llegan a su laboratorio
y su función es elegir entre 2 tareas,
una para ellas y otra para otra persona,
a la cual no van a conocer.
Una de las tareas es
divertida e interesante
y por cada respuesta correcta que
den, consiguen un boleto para
un sorteo en el que ganarán
cierta cantidad de dinero.
La otra tarea es un poco aburrida y
sus respuestas correctas
no les otorgan boletos para el sorteo.
Entonces, las personas pueden decidir
asignarse la tarea divertida,
interesante y con sorteo, y asignar a la
otra persona la tarea aburrida
y sin sorteo.
O bien, asignar a la otra
persona la tarea divertida
e interesante y asignarse a ellas la
tarea aburrida y sin sorteo.
Lo que los psicólogos llaman VD,
o variable dependiente,
lo que estudia Batson en busca de las
diferencias, es el porcentaje
de veces que las personas se
asignan la tarea positiva
y asignan a la otra persona
la tarea neutral.
Si lo hiciéramos al azar,
si echáramos un volado,
¿qué porcentaje de las veces
saldría la tarea positiva?
¿Qué porcentaje de las veces se
asignarían las personas
la tarea positiva? Indiquen el
porcentaje con los dedos,
supongan que cada dedo vale 10%.
Lo pueden hacer con una mano:
50%. Si solo echáramos
un volado, el 50% de las veces nos
tocaría la tarea positiva
y el 50% de las veces la otra persona
obtendría la tarea positiva.
Esa es una de las cosas que Batson
está midiendo en sus estudios.
La otra cosa, es la
calificación que las personas
se asignan sobre qué tan moral
consideran su acción.
Si consideran que su acción
fue perfectamente moral
al realizar la tarea, se asignan un 9.
Si consideran que su acción fue
perfectamente inmoral
al realizar la tarea, se asignan un 1.
Esas son las cosas que
Batson está midiendo.
Ese es el término más importante en
psicología: la variable dependiente.
Lo que observas en tus estudios para
descubrir las diferencias.
Quienes han tomado clases de psicología
o han tenido compañeros que han
tomado clases de psicología,
saben que cuando se realizan
estudios psicológicos,
los sujetos se enfrentan a condiciones.
Es decir, cuando llegan,
les pasa una cosa
o les pasa otra.
La semilla que describí en el
estudio científico podría estar
en la condición de tierra y
agua, pero sin aire,
o podría estar en la condición de
tierra y canciones, pero sin agua.
De la misma manera, los
sujetos de Batson
podrían estar en el caso de que llegan
y se les explica que hay
estas 2 posibilidades.
Pueden asignarse la tarea
positiva o asignar la negativa
a otra persona, o se les
plantea otro escenario
en el que pueden usar la suerte
para tomar la decisión.
En la guía de lectura, les pedí
que intentaran comprender
la tabla en la que Batson
presenta sus resultados.
En los siguientes minutos de la
clase quiero explicarles
qué significan los resultados tan
interesantes que obtuvo.
En la primera condición, cuando los
sujetos llegan y se les dice
que pueden hacer la tarea como
quieran, 80% de los sujetos,
8 de 10, se asignan la
condición positiva
y asignan a la otra persona la
condición negativa. ¿Entendido?
El 80% de las personas eligen
la opción egoísta,
pero no consideran haber sido
especialmente generosos.
Se evalúan con un 4,
en una escala de moralidad del 1 al 9.
Aquellos que asignan la condición
positiva a la otra persona
se evalúan muy alto.
Consideran haber hecho lo correcto.
Si traes sujetos a una sala y les dices
que pueden echar un volado, pero
que no tienen que hacerlo,
aproximadamente la mitad no lo
harán. Y de esa mitad,
el 90% se asignarán la
condición positiva. Nada raro.
El siguiente número es un
resultado sorprendente.
¿Qué pasa cuando los
sujetos llegan a la sala
y se les dice que pueden echar un volado
y según los resultados del volado,
asignarse una condición
y asignar otra condición
a otra persona?
Resulta que, después de echar el
volado, 90% de los sujetos
se asignan la condición positiva.
Solamente levantamos 5
dedos de una mano.
¿Qué está pasando?
¿Qué pasaría si tú echas el volado
y sale águila? ¿Qué significa?
"¡Ah, águila! Águila debe
significar que me asigno
la condición positiva y que asigno la
condición negativa a mi oponente".
Si sale sol: "Sol. ¡Ah, sol! Eso
significa que me asigno la condición
positiva y que asigno la condición
negativa a mi oponente".
Esto es lo sorprendente: 90% de las
personas echaron el volado,
se asignaron la condición positiva
y consideran que actuaron
de forma sumamente moral.
Evalúan su comportamiento con un 7 de
9 con respecto a la moralidad.
Y la única persona que echó el
volado y le hizo caso,
se evaluó con un 9. Bien.
Batson está preocupado por
esto y entonces dice:
Veré si puedo controlar esto
cambiando las opciones de águila o sol.
Usaré monedas que de un lado digan
"tarea positiva para ti"
y del otro "tarea negativa
para el oponente".
¿Qué pasa en ese caso?
¿Qué hicieron el 86% de los
sujetos que echaron el volado
y salía "tarea negativa para el
oponente"? ¿Ustedes que harían?
Lo echan otra vez hasta que salga…
"¡Ese no vale! El que vale es...
debe ser el volado 14 el
que realmente vale".
Y esas personas, otra vez, se
evalúan como si hubieran actuado
de forma completamente moral.
Incluso cuando Batson pone
etiquetas de colores,
para poder ver a través de la
ventana lo que hacen,
sigue obteniendo el mismo
patrón sorprendente.
En 8 de 10, 9 de 10 casos, cuando las
personas tienen la oportunidad
de aparentar que han actuado moralmente,
lo harán aunque en realidad
se hayan aprovechado de una
situación ambigua.
Al parecer, dice Batson
basándose en esto,
a la gente le importa parecer
morales ante sí mismos,
pero no el hecho de actuar
de forma justa.
¿Cómo podemos inducir en la gente
un comportamiento moral prosocial?
Aquí está el siguiente estudio
extraordinario que hizo Batson.
Colocó a los sujetos, que participaban
en el mismo diseño experimental,
en una sala con un espejo.
Si el espejo no mira al sujeto
y el sujeto no se refleja en él,
se obtienen exactamente los mismos
resultados que la vez pasada.
Aproximadamente el 85% de los sujetos se
asignan la condición positiva.
Si el espejo está enfrente de ellos
y se reflejan en él, y echan el volado,
solo 62% se asignan la
condición positiva.
Perdón, si el espejo está
enfrente de ellos,
aunque no echen el
volado, 62% se asignan
la condición positiva, es decir,
actúan de forma casi
completamente justa.
Si el espejo está enfrente de
ellos y echan el volado,
50% actúan de forma justa: tal y como
lo pronosticaría la suerte.
¿Qué está pasando aquí?
Parece que el simple hecho de
sentirse observado,
incluso por uno mismo, es suficiente
para provocar un
comportamiento prosocial.
Un fabuloso estudio, realizado
hace 5 años en Inglaterra,
confirma esto. En este estudio,
había un sistema de honor
para poner dinero en un bote si habías
bebido café en el departamento.
Algunas semanas, encima de
la máquina de café
se pegaron fotos de flores.
Flores, flores, flores.
En esas semanas, casi nadie
puso dinero en el bote.
La otra mitad de las semanas
se pegaron unos ojos encima del
bote. En esas semanas,
los sujetos donaron grandes
cantidades de dinero al bote.
Hay algo sobre nosotros
como seres sociales
que nos anima a comportarnos de
forma moral cuando se activa,
consciente o inconscientemente,
la sensación de ser observados.
Si quieres terminar tus tareas
sin procrastinar, pon
unos ojos en tu computadora y un
espejo detrás de tu escritorio.
No estoy bromeando.
La profunda y asombrosa visión de
la historia de Glaucón
sobre Giges en La República,
a la luz de esta investigación
contemporánea, es casi espeluznante.
Glaucón contaba la historia
de cómo esperamos
que alguien se comporte si
considera que nadie lo observa.
La historia del pastor que encuentra
el anillo de invisibilidad,
lo toma y se apodera del reino,
es la historia que cuenta la
investigación de Batson
sobre una inclinación que
tienen los seres humanos.
Hay una tendencia preocupante,
por lo menos, en los
protagonistas de estas
historias.
La antigua civilización griega
creía que la historia del
anillo era verdad.
Los alumnos estadounidenses
contemporáneos de la Universidad
de Kansas parecen confirmarlo.
Cuando pensamos que no somos observados,
es difícil actuar según
los códigos morales.
La pregunta que se repetirá
en todo el semestre,
tanto en la unidad de moralidad como
en la de filosofía política,
es cómo estructurar la sociedad
para que haya el equivalente
a ojos encima de las
computadoras y espejos en las
salas, para que podamos actuar
según las reglas que permiten a
las sociedades proporcionar
la estabilidad necesaria para que
los seres humanos prosperen.
Nos quedan unos minutos.
¿Tienen preguntas sobre
la clase de hoy?
Una pregunta.
Alumno: ¿Las consecuencias de
[inaudible] moralidad [inaudible]?
Catedrática Tamar Gendler: Bien.
Cuando hablé de las
consecuencias de la moralidad,
limité la discusión a las
consecuencias para ustedes,
como su reputación.
La pregunta es: ¿Qué pasa con
otros tipos de consecuencias?
¿Qué pasa cuando mis actos
inmorales perjudican a otros?
Un tema que veremos la próxima semana,
otra vez en la sección de
justicia, es la capacidad humana
de empatizar y compadecerse,
y cómo aprovechar esto
para sean los ojos y espejos que
promuevan acciones prosociales.
Muy buena pregunta.
Alumno: [inaudible] cuando Glaucón
habla sobre esto, [inaudible]
Catedrática Tamar
Gendler: La pregunta es:
cuando Glaucón habla sobre esto,
¿solo habla de temas de reputación?
Pasa algo muy interesante en el
Libro II de La República.
Glaucón y Adimanto hablan de
una conversación sobre
reputación que Sócrates había tenido
con Trasímaco en el Libro I.
En parte, por eso se presenta
como una razón.
También, verán que cuando
Sócrates responde,
habla sobre la integridad de la persona
que actúa de forma moral o inmoral.
En esencia lo que Sócrates dirá es:
"Pareciera que lo único que te importa
es lo que aparentas ante los demás.
Aunque, de hecho, cuando permites
que tu alma se desordene,
cuando actúas por impulso,
sin tomar en cuenta las
necesidades de los otros,
tú mismo serás incapaz de prosperar".
Esa es la respuesta que
vamos a analizar.
Glaucón aún no ha
planteado esa pregunta.
Sócrates la va a plantear
en la conversación.
Bien. Son las 11:20. Espero que la
densidad de la clase de hoy
no asuste a muchos de ustedes.
Se pone más divertido después de esto.
Espero verlos la próxima semana.